por qué
[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida a que américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy empezamos en guatemala donde
se cumplen tres semanas de la detención
del periodista josé rubén zamora
director de un medio de comunicación
crítico con el gobierno de alejandro
giammatei tras sus denuncias de los
presuntos vínculos con la corrupción a
zamora lo acusan de lavado de activos y
tráfico de influencias pero lo cierto es
que su arresto se dio tras la
publicación de una fábula que delataba
la presunta homosexualidad del
mandatario de derecha y vamos a
venezuela donde los pacientes están
teniendo que caminar para llegar a
urgencias pues los hospitales del estado
no tienen ambulancias algunos
voluntarios están prestando el servicio
ante la escasez de estos vehículos en
caracas les contamos con nuestra
corresponsal
y visitamos colombia para la feria de
las flores de la mano de nuestras
enviadas especiales les mostramos la
tradición de las silletas el arte con
flores que cada año se toma la ciudad de
medellín
y vamos de inmediato a guatemala para
nuestra historia principal se cumplieron
tres semanas desde que el reconocido
periodista josé rubén zamora fue
detenido en su domicilio
abiertamente crítico del gobierno zamora
destapó numerosos escándalos de
corrupción en contra del presidente
alejandro giammatei y hoy su arresto
revive el debate decía irrespeto a la
libertad de prensa en guatemala nuestros
corresponsales andrés suárez y aurora
vall nos explican
el allanamiento pues la libertad de
prensa un tema espinoso para ramón
zamora el mismo día que encarcela habana
a su padre reconocido periodista de
oposición también a llenaban su lugar de
trabajo ese 29 de julio ocho
trabajadores fueron retenidos durante 16
horas en las rotativas del matutino el
periódico en la ciudad de guatemala
pues sumamente violento y violento
muchos derechos porque al final de
cuentas en ningún momento notificar a un
por qué estaban entrando que fue muy
similar a lo que sucedió en la casa de
mis padres mientras dos tapas no acá sin
tocar la puerta de sin que nadie les
abriera la puerta de la casa se subieron
al techo para ingresar a la casa de mis
padres
la detención de josé rubén zamora por
cargos de lavado de dinero y
conspiración es considerada por sus
abogados como un montaje político
impostor su historial de investigaciones
periodísticas acabó por costarle la
libertad sobre todo el trabajo donde
vinculó directamente al presidente
alejandro giammatei con casos de
corrupción nunca nadie pensó que en
papal efra pasara algo por ser un pero
está tan reconocido
internacionalmente y si a él le pasó lo
que le está pasando quiere decir que a
cualquier periodista le puede pasar otro
medio históricamente crítico es el grupo
prensa libre su jefe de redacción
antonio barrios teme por el futuro de
los medios in guatemala y el país está
en una situación caminando poco a poco
hacia un clima muy tenso hacia hacia un
clima totalitario probablemente una
realidad a la que andrea domínguez se
enfrenta en el terreno etiquetada de
periodista de oposición por el gobierno
muchas veces le cuesta hacer su trabajo
si suave posición notarás una entrevista
de mandatario y si la tenencia en algún
impacto público el incluso se burla de
los periodistas guatemala no deja de
caer en la clasificación de la libertad
de prensa de reporteros sin fronteras
posicionándose este año en el puesto 124
de los 180 países
sigamos en mexico la comisión de la
verdad creada en 2018 sobre la
desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
aéreo china para determinó que el hecho
fue un crimen de estado concluyó también
que las autoridades federales y
estatales del más alto nivel fueron
omisas y negligentes y les acusó de
alterar los hechos y las circunstancias
el documento menciona que no hay
indicios de que ninguno de los
estudiantes esté vivo lo que constituye
un nuevo capítulo en el caso de los
jóvenes que desaparecieron el 26 de
septiembre de 2014 cuando se dirigía a
la ciudad de mexico para participar en
una manifestación que en todo momento
las autoridades federales estatales y
municipales
tuvieron conocimiento de la movilización
de los estudiantes
desde la salida de la escuela normal
isidro burgos hasta su desaparición
y sus acciones
omisiones y participación permitieron la
desaparición y ejecución de los
estudiantes así como el homicidio de
otras seis personas
vamos ahora a brasil para revisar la
imagen de la semana el expresidente luiz
inácio lula da silva y el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro empezaron oficialmente sus
campañas de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales de octubre una campaña
que se prevé polarizada a finales de
julio el sondeo del instituto datafolha
daba a lula el 47 por ciento de
intención de voto es decir 18 puntos más
que bolsonaro pero en estas últimas
semanas el presidente ultraderechista ha
subido en las encuestas gracias a la
activación de programas para beneficiar
a los sectores de escasos recursos
nuestro país no quiere dar pasos atrás
no queremos ideología de género en las
escuelas nuestro país no quiere
legalizar las drogas nuestro país
respeta la vida desde su concepción
nuestro país no quiere convertirse en un
aliado del comunismo en otros países
quiere decirle presidente genocida que
no queremos un gobierno que distribuya
armas queremos un gobierno que
distribuya libros no queremos un
gobierno que alimente el odio queremos
un gobierno que alimente el amor y vamos
ahora está eeuu porque la república
analista y mi hija del ex presidente
dick cheney y férrea crítica del
exmandatario donald trump fue derrotada
en las primarias por el estado de
wyoming el martes competía por
asegurarse un cuarto periodo en la
cámara de representantes
jane y quien fue una de las pocas
republicanas que conforman el comité que
investiga la insurrección del 6 de enero
de 2021 prometió seguir trabajando para
evitar que trump regrese a la casa
blanca
y seguimos en venezuela donde la falta
de ambulancia se está poniendo en riesgo
la vida de los ciudadanos en 13 de los
23 estados del país la mayoría de los
hospitales no cuentan con estos
vehículos las organizaciones de
protección civil y de bomberos que están
facultados para atender las emergencias
tampoco tienen suficientes unidades en
buen estado para prestar los servicios
el informe desde nuestra corresponsal en
caracas daniela zambrano
reina rodríguez y su esposo vivieron
horas de angustia cuando su hijo de
siete años sufrió un accidente en un
parque tras muchas llamadas infructuosas
al servicio de ambulancias su esposo
tuvo que caminar con el niño en brazos
por más de 25 minutos para conseguir un
vehículo que le trasladará al hospital
nunca la ambulancia pudieron ni en la
noche ni en la mañana pero siempre
llamamos siempre explicamos el caso que
era un niño todo no no lo pudieron
prestar el servicio según la
organización mundial de la salud
deberían contabilizarse una ambulancia
por cada 25 mil habitantes sin embargo
en venezuela no se cumple con esta regla
la falta de repuestos y dinero para la
reparación ha hecho que decenas de estos
vehículos de los hospitales públicos
hayan sido abandonados en diferentes
estacionamientos incluyendo los de las
estaciones de bomberos el vicepresidente
de la academia nacional de medicina
advierte que esta situación pone en
riesgo la vida de los pacientes por lo
que un paciente con politraumatismo a un
accidente de tránsito el 50% se muere en
el accidente dependiendo la gravedad y
otro 20 tanto a 30% se muere en el
traslado porque
condicionado no por comodidad sino por
resguardar al paciente deben tener
sirena deben tener sistema de freno una
cantidad de cosas que no hay ante la
falta de ambulancias han surgido
iniciativas ciudadanas es el caso de un
grupo de jóvenes paramédicos que desde
hace casi cuatro años se dedican a
prestar atención prehospitalaria
gratuita jonathan quantic su fundador
cuenta que en el 2020 lograron adquirir
una ambulancia con donaciones y
organismos internacionales los tratamos
de apoyar a las autoridades cuando se
ven sobrepasadas también
estamos capacitados para dar atención en
cuanto a las emergencias médicas este
infarto
[Música]
emergencia metabólica
han pasado tres semanas y rainer acude
nuevamente al hospital para cambio de
yeso tras la fractura de tibia el
traslado sigue siendo a pie aunque ahora
con el apoyo de una silla de ruedas
prestada el déficit de ambulancias para
traslados programados en venezuela es
aún mayor su familia como una mayoría no
cuenta con los recursos para pagar un
servicio privado que en promedio podría
costarle 50 dólares o más
y los invito a colombia en medellín tuvo
lugar la feria de las flores un homenaje
a los campesinos del estado de antioquia
en su edición número 65 y luego de dos
años de pandemia recoge y muestra un
saber que se pasa entre generaciones las
silletas más de 500 campesinos llegan a
la ciudad con decorados de flores en su
espalda que tienen también un legado
familiar nuestras enviadas especiales
manuel a cano y diana sánchez nos traen
la historia
que la paloma más de 10 sombreros
descansan en la cama de jose por la
mitad
y alto un granito cada uno representa
una participación en el desfile final de
la feria de las flores un concurso que
gracias a las silletas unas estructuras
de madera repletas de imágenes hechas de
flores colorean cada agosto la ciudad de
medellín en el oeste de colombia se
trata de la celebración de un saber
campesino
uno que nace en el cultivo de la tierra
su jardín atrae a miles de visitantes
que observan sus 65 tipos de flores
jose no esconde su emoción de volver a
desfilar una alegría no hay palabras
para expresar lo que no siempre cargar
de estas galletas cientos de silleteros
viven en santa elena un corregimiento a
pocos kilómetros de medellín donde late
el corazón de la feria de las flores una
que comenzó hacia 65 años desde entonces
la tradición se cultiva en familia como
la finca de los london yo en su interior
primos tíos y hermanos no se despegan de
las mesas donde descansan sus nietas es
una carrera contra el tiempo una maratón
en la que participan como equipo luís
felipe lo sabe bien en tiempos estábamos
ajustados quedaría el tiempo para
ducharme y ya salir hacia medellín con
la ola villeta una tradición familiar
que se remonta a siglos atrás las
silletas eran usadas para transportar a
personas enfermas o heridas
las flores llegaron un tiempo después y
cambiaron su significado
clark aporta toda esa historia en su
sillita gracias a un contrato uno que
pasa entre generaciones como la herencia
más preciada cuando yo ya no puedo
cargar mis nietas que el médico me diga
doña claro y sé por motivos de salud no
puede cargar más su sillita
yo no le pasaría mi contrato a mi esposo
sino que se lo pasaría a mi hijo que
sería como el legado que él seguiría con
esa tradición
el día del desfile final las silletas se
extienden por una enorme avenida de
medellín como un museo al aire libre
allí son examinadas por jurados deben
ser levantadas por sus artistas
carolina acaba de graduarse de seguridad
ocupacional pero para ella levantar su
sillita es el verdadero examen final es
un legado alegada de la familia de la
abuela de mi mamá
que por ellas estoy aquí
ocho categorías más de 500 participantes
y miles de ojos puestos sobre la avenida
del río medellín vibra con el paso de
cada silletero
y aunque sólo uno fue el ganador
absoluto todos reciben un grito
entusiasta de una ciudad entera que
muestra admiración al saber del
campesinado antioqueño
gracias por acompañarme en aquí américa
en la producción estuvo andrés doncel
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web france24 puntocom
por favor envíenme sus comentarios en
redes sociales a la dirección que ven en
su pantalla y para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]
atentamente